hey they're crazy I was just having this
conversation with question pallone why
am i this size well you're human and
you're my clone so you have to be the
size why are humans this size oh wow
that's a great topic for a video I gotta
think about this hey what were you going
so let's see what we can do with this
first we could have just as easily been
a slightly different size as we can see
from the usual suspects I mean that's
just chance yeah but why are we way
bigger because not everything scales the
same way in a normal size Hume is kind
of like a scale model of a giant human
so let's make a list things that scale
with a volume include mass which can
affect how you resist changes in your
motion weight which is how much gravity
pulls down on you and heat generated
because you have a lot more cells doing
more stuff things that scale with area
include bone and muscle strength because
thats related to cross-section and heat
dissipated because thats related to
exposed skin area side note don't ever
let anyone tell you you lose more heat
through your head you lose heat through
any exposed skin no matter where it is
and if side note okay let's say we make
a clone that's I don't know 10 times
taller they'd have a thousand times the
mass a thousand times the weight and
would be generating a thousand times as
much heat yikes
but unfortunately they'd only have a
hundred times the strength and they'd
only be dissipating a hundred times the
heat so basically they wouldn't have the
strength to move their body their bones
would break under the weight of their
body and they burn up from the inside
until their organs shut down but yes
there used to be things like dinosaurs
and mammoths but yes there are still
elephants and giraffes but what about
and yes floating can take some of the
weight off the bones and muscles so
aquatic animals have an easier time
being bigger
the point is humans can't be that big so
then why aren't we waist smaller mmm
that one's a little harder but let's see
what we can do the big problem here is
our thought holes also known as our
brains brains brains cells or neurons
are some of the smallest cells in the
human body at least in diameter and it
still takes a brain this big to give us
our level of intelligence but
elephants have okay okay it's not just
about brain size larger animals like
elephants do have bigger brains than us
in fact they have about three times as
many neurons but that doesn't mean the
elephant is three times smarter than us
naturally bigger animals have bigger
brains because there's more stuff to
control over 97% of those elephant
neurons are found in the cerebellum the
part of the brain most responsible for
motor control it needs all those neurons
just to control all it's big clunky
parts so what about a brain to body mass
ratio something like that has been
suggested before we call it an
encephalization quotient or EQ which is
the ratio between actual brain mass and
the brain mass we predict would be
necessary to control the body cats have
an EQ of one chimps about 2.5 bottlenose
dolphins between 4 and 5 and humans sit
comfortably at about 7 that certainly
puts us on top but we usually attribute
higher intelligence to the cerebral
cortex which is that wrinkly part on the
outside of our brains and only mammals
have it which is pretty arrogant if you
asked me limiting intelligence to
mammals crows are pretty smart and they
don't have a cerebral cortex octopuses
are really smart and they don't have a
cerebral cortex in fact 2/3 of their
neurons are in their arms which are not
tentacles by the way those neurons allow
each arm to act independently of the
others and the central brain it's a
completely different kind of
intelligence ok I concede intelligence
is complicated but there is another
problem you'd run into if you were
smaller your lungs if you get small
enough like insects small lows are
unnecessary it would be more energy
efficient to just absorb oxygen through
your skin insects do it through little
holes in their exoskeleton Superman
ultimate point different sized organisms
have to work with a different set of
rules our rules only work at our size
but here's the real question why do we
have any size at all we'll try to find
an answer on the next episode of the
science asylum make sure you subscribe
so you don't miss it
thanks for liking and sharing this video
and until next time remember
it's okay to be a little crazy in the
last video we talked about Planck units
comment response time rogue assassin
gaming was wondering if plot length is
the shortest distance then could plug
time be the shortest amount of time yes
in fact the same models of quantum
gravity say that about length and time
but again they don't have any
experimental evidence so for now plunk
time is just the time it takes for light
to travel one plot length and as we said
in that video it was the age of the
universe when it was one plunk length
across papa k heard one time that if you
try to measure the Planck scale you'll
create a black hole well maybe a typical
way to measure position is to use light
and the wavelength of that light is your
precision to measure Planck length the
photon has to have an energy of 12
billion joules or six plunk energies
basically you just turned half a fruit
fly into one photon that much mass
energy would create a black hole if it
was smushed into one Planck length but
just because a photon is a wavelength
that small it doesn't mean that's the
size of the photon wavelength and size
are not necessarily the same thing
camera vac suggested we should switch to
a base 12 or base 16 number system you
know 12 does have a lot more factors
than 10 so it would certainly make
writing decimals easier but I think
you'd have a hard time convincing anyone
to change we can't even get the u.s. to
switch to the metric system Pablo had
some very astute criticisms for using
blackbody radiation to define Planck
temperature for those of you who don't
know blackbody radiation is just light
emitted by an object due solely to its
temperature so basically the vibrations
and collisions between molecules it's
commonly stated that if an object is
plumb temperature hot then it will emit
light that has a wavelength of one plant
length but the problem was saying this
is not just one type of photon is
emitted by the object blackbody
radiation is distributed over many
wavelengths you are emitting it right
now it's just mostly infrared one plow
temperature gives you a peak wavelength
of one plant length something could be
at half a plot temperature and still be
emitting light at one Planck length just
not as much and to anyone like an
infinity pool who thinks this channel
doesn't get enough attention share the
videos all the places
anyway thanks for watching